sterling k Brown gets emotional about
his new hit show this is us it's been an
embarrassment of riches
ET spoke with the 40 year old actor at
the good+ foundations first-ever
halloween bash on sunday where he opened
up about the most difficult scene he's
filmed for the show thus far I had a
scene on Friday night that started at
5pm and we didn't finish till around
three o'clock in the morning it was just
one scene and Helen Hunt is directing it
and it was quite extensive but that's
all I can say about it but Chris
Christmas episode sterling also got
emotional over the parallels between his
own life and it's characters was tough
it's tough I lost my dad when I was a
young man and so I feel acutely this
sort of connection to fathers and father
figures so it's been strangely
therapeutic for me to go through this
journey as Randall and his his daddy
issues you know I'm saying but it's it's
definitely like I think about my dad all
the time and I know he's smiling at the
fact that I get a chance to do this part
right now and go on this journey and I
hope I just doing problem that's that's
all
you